you are always been a terrific stand-up
an amazing stand-up comedian
very talented and i was curious i heard
you say once
it was in an interview that you get some
of your comedic sensibility from your
dad
and i'm wondering really is it first of
all how is he doing how is your dad
he has passed away no i'm just kidding
he um
he's not always awkward he gets scared
that's a good did your heart just drop a
little bit no i was pretty sure he
hadn't but yeah
i thought maybe like got off the phone
just got off news
yeah just kidding dad he is always
counting down because he looked up like
how much longer he has to live
according to some app but um he turns 80
this year
he has really deformed feet what do you
mean
from an accident i honestly i sent the
segment producer a picture of his feet
and
he was like we can't show this on tv
did something happen did he put him in a
lawnmower when he was younger or
he just says wildly deformed feet his
podiatrist said they're the ugliest feet
she's ever seen in her life
they're ugly he just had to get two toes
removed oh
and oh no they're a very sympathetic
crowd
planes he's always just like yeah i
gotta get two toes removed i go
oh my god dad which ones this is how he
knows his toes he goes the one that had
roast beef and the
one that went to market
i don't know that's a medical
terminology
that's fantastic yeah he's very thick
your dad yeah he's got that thick boston
accent
uh he is he got a tattoo oh
okay is this right it was probably two
or three years ago now is for my
stepmother's 70th birthday
my sister laura convinced him she has a
bunch of tattoos and she convinced them
wouldn't it be cool to get
janice's name on your ass and so he did
it and
she videotaped it and he is screaming
the whole time
and it's the funniest thing this is a
man in his
seven late 70s at this point getting a
tattoo
in july oh my god all right and you you
brought the video
yeah i don't know what part of it but
it's a little sliver let's take a look
[Laughter]
wait daddy oh i can't talk to you right
now laura i get it
man that is fantastic
uh i love that too someone in pain with
a boston accent
oh i can't talk to you now i'm in pain
uh does he get out here to la to see you
much
he they always come for thanksgiving and
uh
i usually have like a straggler's
thanksgiving you know in my apartment
so like just any comics that aren't
don't have plans where they come over
show folk we call them folk and uh and
but my dad and my some of them have been
coming and then um
it's funny because my friend stephanie
zambari i was walking by she was talking
to he was sitting in a chair and she was
like sitting at his feet and they were
talking and as i walked
by i heard her go
to my dad and i go stephanie don't talk
to my dad like that
and she goes he just told me i should
kill myself
this is such a great thanksgiving oh
yeah wow why was he
what was it so did you figure it out i'm
an instigator he's an instigator i mean
i don't know why but then this past year
he walked in the door and she was in the
kitchen because we she makes like a lot
of the
food and um he just looked at i didn't
think he would remember and he just
looked at her and he goes you're still
alive
that's his way i want to come over i
want to come over and see this on
thanksgiving